I I'm
I don't know why I feel nervous but like
was it at all controversial leaving the
Eric Andre show
no not controversial
it was uh
the reason I left was because
it was a gap in between
that just felt
a bit
unnatural to me for to jump back in okay
uh like because of the first four
seasons were boom boom boom boom right
and then it was just it wasn't happening
um for a bit
and so then
I thought it I thought the show wasn't
happening anymore right which is fine
too you know and so then
going back in
uh
yeah it didn't feel because it was out
of rhythm you know what I'm saying I you
know it's a lot of things you do in that
that amount of time and so right it's
just jumping back in didn't feel it you
know that show was very sort of
uncomfortable you know you make the
guess it's kind of uncomfortable at
least like in a comedic way yeah like
you sitting there are you was that easy
for you were you like oh this is no big
deal like they're uncomfortable I'm cool
or were you kind of like feeling awkward
or uncomfortable a lot of the time
yeah sometimes because it's
it's not a
it's not a normal way to interact with
people right
well sure and so and it's you know cut
down too right right you know what I'm
saying so it's
so yeah so sometimes those are going
hour two hours to cut to two three so
you know there's sometimes where it's
just it is really really weird
or fun
some of them
rapper Ninja Warrior
was really fun you know what I'm saying
some of the performances some of the
moments I truly like exciting in there
some of them are weird as hell and up
and down and then it's cut down and it's
amazing right uh but then some are
genuinely you know you look at the
rapper Warrior Ninja
clip I'm genuinely laughing uh-huh at
that on that's not me faking it I can't
believe this is happening in front of me
and so there's a lot of those those type
of moments too or even that's one where
the guys are hanging upside down I was
there for that and I was like hitting
them with tennis balls and [ __ ] yeah
then again but then again maybe you did
that I think you might have did the
second one I think it might have been
the second one yeah uh there's a rap
competition these guys are hanging
upside down having to rap while they're
hanging upside down and basically being
tortured yeah just doing different
things so that one was I couldn't
because it felt like you know is this
what are what are the legal
ramifications
that [ __ ] this shouldn't be somebody's
gonna get hurt but although this is I
can't believe he's he's having a couple
of folks friends too Danny Brown was
there uh open mike Eagles so it was just
you know it was it was that those were
wow yeah when you're hanging upside down
you can't get like you're stuck yeah
yeah yeah and but like would you ever go
up to a someone like after the show be
like hey like sorry I'm not really like
that it's nice to meet you this is the
real me like kind of or you know uh no
not that much because I didn't feel that
responsibility as the co-host yeah
that's true because I wasn't the driving
force so I didn't right uh I didn't
really yeah I didn't really do it like
that maybe I should have though because
that it is
it is somewhere I'm like oh do they
think even if it is television that I
win or it was fun that is you know some
people's first time meeting me and [ __ ]
right exactly in that context uh it's a
it's a wild show man it's a lot of it's
a lot of stuff on that that Cutting Room
floor for show yeah I mean I feel like
that Eric Andre show is reminiscent like
the weirdness of like the old Tom Green
Show but just so souped up and on acid
like yeah well Tom Green was like kind
of messing with his friends you know
like when he was on that set he would go
out on the on the street and really [ __ ]
with people but Eric Andre is like
messing with like famous people which is
like a whole other level really upset I
mean they had their and sometimes I
some people seem more who was really
upset
was Lou Ferrigno
I could picture that I think he's a guy
like an earlier season
yeah but I wasn't
because it's
out of dynamic and I'm standing up a lot
too I'm like
not fully
connected in the experience if you get
what I mean as far as like you're like
the guy yeah as far as even the the the
the guests
uh emotional art too you know I mean I'm
just there like any minute like saying
random [ __ ] uh especially if I don't
know anybody get pissed and be like you
can't air this like [ __ ] you guys I
think that they sign a release form
before they start rolling I mean that's
always the goal so yeah I don't know
because that that's that's you know on
the producer end of the game and and all
of that so I'm not I'm not dealing with
those those parts right but I'm sure
some people will like
uh because it it probably you know feels
weird afterwards
why did I why did I do that what am I
you know you got to question a few
things like it's it's a it's a it's a
weird yeah it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're at ranked number
30 on all of Amazon and if you buy a
bottle we might go up the ladder and
that would mean a lot so please get on
Amazon and buy Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole yeah
yeah dude